hello everyone and welcome back to the
opera euro rapid tournament we are in
the second day and this is the second
game of the day uh alexander grisham
versus magnus carlsen it's
quite the struggle uh so uh let's dive
straight into it
uh and also before before we check out
the game i would just like to
uh wish a very happy birthday to diego
who is enjoying the show from mexico
with his two kids
i hope you have a good one and all the
best in the upcoming year
now uh that being said let's check out
the game uh so grishok with the white
pieces opens with e4
magnus as you already know uh uh lately
replies with the sicilian we have c5
knight to f3 knight to c6 and now knight
to c3
sasha avoids the main line with d4 uh we
have
e5 now uh grabbing hold of the center
here
and now bishop to c4 by grishok uh we
have g6
uh preparing to fiance to the dark
square bishop
and now d3 and here h6 uh not allowing
the bishop to be nicely developed here
we have castles by grishok and now
bishop to g7
and now uh there are a couple of moves
that reach this position but here
uh issue goes for a3 and it is already
as of move 7 that we have a completely
new game he's preparing
some tricky lines with b for as you'll
see so here magnus continues development
d6 and now the immediate b4
uh something similar to the mangarini
variation uh with the
early a3b4 the idea is you want to give
up this spawn to make it really uh hard
for black to develop
something like d4 you strike immediately
in the center and after let's say
captures you're going to play knight to
b5
and now you have problems uh because
bishop to a3 is coming
with and there's going to be a lot of
pressure here on the pawn here you can't
play really a6 because you
you you will not be able to capture the
knight the rook will be hanging
and if you just try and castle just
bishop the a3
comes with an attack on the knight and
now there's not much that can be done
the knight cannot move otherwise this is
captured and like we said a6 doesn't
really do anything
uh because you're gonna have to after
captures captures you will have to give
up the exchange uh
after rook captain on a8 but you don't
even have to give up the bishop for
nothing so you can just capture on f7
and after king captures only then
grab the rook and now white's position
is just much better so there are a lot
very very very tricky ideas behind it
this b4 move
and uh more often than not uh there are
tricky ideas behind
every b4 move so here magnus just
ignores that
he goes knight g to e7 and now uh b
captures on c5 and here uh interestingly
agriculture took some time to consider
this position
i think over three minutes not quite
four but i think three and a half
minutes to go for this
captures on c5 but okay magnus
recaptures and now
bishop to e3 he goes after carlson c5
pawn
uh magnus defense would be six and now
knight to d5 so just improving the
activity of his pieces
bishop to e6 by magnus and now knight
captures on e7 we have queen captures
and the bishop to d5
now threatening bishop captures knight
here and you you never want to capture
something like this because then c4 and
you have a nicely cemented
d5 pass pawn it's going to be a lot of
problems for black so here magnus just
plays rook to c8
and now we have uh c4 so now
if black ever captures here on d five
white is gonna have a beautiful
past pawn here uh so here magnus just
castles and the situation on the clock
is some nine minutes for uh grishok and
some 14 minutes for magnus so magnum is
not really
wasting a lot of time here and here
bishop to d2 now sasha wants to shift
his bishop over to this diagonal
we have rook f the e8 and now rook to e1
we have queen to d7 by magnus maybe with
ideas of shifting the knight over
at the e7 maybe g5 knight g6 maybe maybe
knight
it can come to f4 uh who knows so h3
by grishok and now comes bishop captures
on d5 only now magnus captures
as he wants to bring his knights to d4
and then if grishop wants to eliminate
it then magnus will also get a very nice
pawn
so e captures on d5 and now knight to d4
so you don't want to allow this knight
to remain here so knight captures on uh
d4
c captures on d4 and now queen to b3
uh we have f5 by magnus opening up his
king a little bit but he plans to tuck
it safely to h7
and hope that nothing nothing bad will
happen so here
gurishu could start doubling up on the e
file he decides to go f3 next uh
kind of prevent magnus from pushing e4
and now
queen to c7 going after the c4 pawn yes
for the moment is defended but
after e4 comes you're gonna try and
overload this
defender here so here rook ate the c1
adding another defender early on
and the king to h7 by magnus we have
rook to e2
uh now preparing to double up on the e
file and the situation on the clock is
four minutes for uh grishok and
nine minutes for magnus and here we have
a5
now with ideas as this dark square
bishop isn't
doing all that much here he's locked in
by his own pawns maybe he can shift it
over to c5 so here
rook the b1 going after the pawn here
rook to ba defending and now
a4 not allowing any b5 ids in the future
and now like we mentioned bishop to f8
preparing bishop to c5
so rook b back to e1 putting pressure on
the pawn here and
bishop to c5 and now grisha goes for a
very interesting idea
uh bishop to f4 with a triple attack on
the pawn here of course you cannot
capture as the rook would hang
so here bishop back to d6 preparing to
now um
uh well just just defending the pawn
there still isn't uh
any danger of actually capturing here so
here bishop back to c1 now preparing
bishop to a3
and now bishop back to b4 attacking the
rook here
uh bishop to d2 again offering a trade
and bishop back to c5 by magnus we have
bishop therefore
once again bishop to d6 and now uh
interestingly grisha was down to two and
a half minutes here when he started
thinking
and then he spent another minute
thinking about whether to repeat the
position or maybe play something else
and in the end he decided for king to h1
sort of getting his king away from from
the dark square as carlson does have a
dark square bishop
and now he says you play a move and then
i will decide whether i'm going to
repeat or not but here magnus says
all right we're not going to repeat g5
and now
magnus is going for it so bishop to c1
and bishop back to b for now again
attacking the bishop d2 bishop back to
c5
uh we have bishop to c1 and now rook to
e7 magnus now plans to double up on the
e file
and maybe finally push that e4 pawn so
bishop to a3 once again
and now bishop queen to d6 threatening
to capture the bishop on a3
rook to a1 agriculture defense and now
king to g7 magnus starts to bring his
king into the game
as he feels the things could uh you know
lighten up
so rook to b2 uh and now comes
rook b back to e8 so again preparing to
push some pawns here and only now grisha
decides to go for it bishop captures on
c5
b captures and queen to b6 offering a
trade but also going after after some
pawns here
so queen captures on b6 rook captures
and
now e4 finally magnus gets his e4 move
in
uh with d6 by grishok going after the
rook here
rook to d7 and only now f captures on e4
so now going for some trades captures d
captures rook captures and
now rook to c6 preparing rook to c7
which would force a trade here because
the king is still on the seventh rank
and you cannot go here because the pawn
defends
this so king f6 magnus doesn't allow
this and now
rook captures on c5 magnus grabs the d6
pawn
and now rook the d1 if you go for rook
captures on a5 then
d3 is already coming and it's going to
be very very hard to defend this
so grishok instead instead blocks the
pawn rook to d1
and now kinked uh and now d3 by magnus
with king to g1
and now here magnus played pawn to d2
but maybe there was a
an in-between move of rook to e5 the
idea being that if captured then your
king is getting closer to the action and
you don't have to worry about these two
pawns because the rook will take care of
them
and other than that there really is no
is no better move
you could move the rook all the way back
uh to c8 but then you improve the
position of your rook and then you can
start bringing the king into the game
but okay and magnus also wants to play
really quickly because uh sasha is very
low on time so he plays d2
and now king to f2 we have king to g6 by
magnus and now
rook to d5 uh now just offering a trade
here
uh so rook to f6 with check king to g3
and now
rook captures on c4 uh we have rook one
captures on d2
and magnus grabs the a4 pawn and now we
have a rook end game where magnus is up
upon and it's a past
uh a pawn so can he do something about
this
we have looked at the eighth grisha
wants to get his rook behind the pass
pawn
as you should always do rook to e4
and now rook to g8 this comes with check
so king h5
magnus not afraid because pawns cannot
go over a king if they could it'd be
terrible
so instead rook back to a8 going after
the pawn here
and rook to f5 magnus just defended king
h2
now g4 uh not allowing white to play g4
because this would be
a pretty big deal so here magnus pushes
g4
and now comes rook to a2 preparing to
collect the da5 pawn
rook eat the e5 now defending and now
rook to a4 putting pressure on the g4
pawn so rook to g5
and here uh sasha just trades everything
off h captures on g4 with
check rook captures uh with rook
captures on a5 uh rook
captures on a5 and now rook captures on
a5 and now
it's a rook and a rook's end game with
both sides having only one pawn and
of course we all know what did that mean
so rook to g5 we have rook to a3
king the g6 rook to a6 with check
uh king to h5 now comes rook to a3 king
to g6 rook to a6 check and here
came to h5 and after uh sasha played
rook to a3
it was in this position on move 65 that
the players agreed to a draw
as there is nothing more to be done here
but it was extremely interesting how
uh sasha always plays it uh all the way
he
does not even think of accepting a draw
with the white pieces even though his
opponent is magnus carlsen
and he tried pushing all the way even at
at the expense of maybe getting a
slightly worse position but he still
wanted to play he still wanted to push
and in the end he got an incredibly
fighting draw so that's
how you should play chess and that's
what you should strive for
not just you know okay i'm playing the
world champion i'm begging for a draw
here no grishok wanted to
uh to you know grab a full point and he
didn't
he he doesn't care who he's playing
against so really uh really
amazing stuff and a great showmanship by
by sasha here
so we'll see what happens next in the
tournament and uh yeah i hope you guys
enjoyed that
i would like to thank aaron hoff tom
derelau newt pascal gerald fournier uh
jacob bishop and benjamin hoyberg for
contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing the coverage of
the
of this wonderful uh tournament checking
up on your one of suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day